[Music]
welcome to the jerry spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka mr nimbus and it's time to turn off
nintendo 69
as we're going to be breaking down
episode 2 of rick and morty season 5.
throughout this video we'll be going
over the easter eggs cool little details
and also
recapping and reviewing the story i was
taking a holiday in an alternate
dimension last week
so at the end of the video i'm going to
be going through some of my favorite
easter eggs from episode 1
and discussing my thoughts on the show
full spoilers ahead so if you're a
little brick like pickle rick and don't
want anything ruined then i have
no idea why you're here smash the thumbs
up button if you enjoyed the video and
if you're in then make sure you click
the subscribe button you son of a [ __ ]
without the way let's get into rick and
morty
okay so the episode is called
multiplicity which is a play on the 1996
film multiplicity starring michael
keaton
that two deals with duplicates
doppelgangers and clones
we start off with the family having a
meal only to see that they're ambushed
by killer squid aliens
in a scene that's very reminiscent to
the dream one in american werewolf in
london
we then get a reference to werewolves
when a version of rick and morty watch a
tv show called wenwolf
about a time travelling werewolf this is
playing on who
what when where and why to show when in
time he's traveling back to
and when the creature warps in there's a
very similar effect to how the
terminator appears
he comes across a vampire who has fled
back in time to avoid persecution
as christianity hasn't been invented yet
the vampire itself is based on the
design that appeared way earlier in the
series
and this was carried across to the blade
joke in last week's episode
the whole idea of this episode is kind
of playing on the notion of body doubles
something that several politicians and
public figures have used over the years
in case assassins attempt to kill him
or they just had a heavy spoilers
birthday party that they didn't want to
go to
now in this intro they talk about
jerry's job interview which
makes rick realize something is off rick
and morty also say in their next mission
that they're gonna go and kill god
the christian one because he's been
asleep for so long
this is kind of a nod to how the big guy
used to get involved in things
in the bible but has missed out on said
birthday party for the last 2000 years
which i'm not happy about now we cut to
another family chasing mr always wants
to be hunted
who always wants to be hunted not only
is he one of the worst characters the
show has ever introduced
he also looks a lot like a melted mr
poopy butthole
interestingly he ends up hunting them
throughout the episode at several points
showing what happens when you don't hunt
him now we think this is the real family
and rick talks about why he made the
decoys he brings up space beth which is
of course a nod to the orc in which we
couldn't tell who the real beth was
she appears later on in the episode as
the family seemingly returned home
but whether this is the real one or not
we just don't know at this point
now diane is also mentioned and that's
twice in a row that her name is popped
up
so who knows we may even see her quite
soon for seasons now
fans have pondered over whether the rick
and morty that we've been following
are actually the original ones from c137
by the end of it it's gonna be
impossible to know if this is the case
i think the creative team are just
trolling us throughout this entire
episode by making us think that we
finally have the real ones before
they're killed off
fans often want to hold on to the theory
that we're definitely following the real
sanchez and smith family
but they've just clearly showed us you
can never truly believe that
and this is one of the craziest episodes
that we've ever had
we very much end up like the famalam not
knowing what's real and what isn't
but in the end does it really matter now
we next jump to italy to see the family
living the high life
but they're quickly wiped out and i
don't know if it was intentional but
jerry ends up looking like a pizza
that's
also on the front of a t-shirt in one of
the suitcases
yes it's a reach now interestingly rick
hasn't drank alcohol so far in this
season
so maybe the guys went to total or maybe
he's not the real rick anymore there's
also never been any drool around his
mouth because of this
and i'm not even sure that rick burps at
all at any point in the season
also shout out to seiko queso on reddit
for pointing out that one of the
passcodes is 80085
which if you look at it could spell out
boobs now rick gets morty to check if
he's the real one by looking to see if
there's a barcode on his left butt cheek
which might be a note to the sixth day
in which clones had indicated under
their eyeballs to show if they were real
or not
jerry is making lemon squares which are
gluten-free
sugar-free and lemon-free now they go to
another decoy family
and discover that they were making
decoys the previous rick did mention
that decoys wouldn't make decoys
and that they also wouldn't go to
hideout with another decoy family
which they go to do they drop a line
about decoys not knowing whether they're
a machine
similar to westworld which is a nod to
bernard and several characters in the
show
not realizing that they themselves are
machines upon telling the decoy this
hilariously
their head explodes now rick realizes
that he has to destroy the rest of the
decoys
and the rest of the decoys have the same
idea summer says she thinks that they're
actually decoys
and yeah it gets super super confusing
like my brain hurts
please don't be a decoy definition paul
just just please no
they go to a home and from another
perspective we watch is the situation
that just happened plays out almost
identically
however the fact that the decoy rick
asks where the other rick was
triggers the third rick to realize the
other decoys are there
i know a lot of people think that this
is just the previous situation playing
out from a different perspective
but there are some changes to show us
that this is something different
the self-termination program is
something that rick has clearly set up
so the situation handles itself
but it does lead to a lot of confusion
on the board we can see several circles
that represent one family
and they themselves create several other
families which
in turn create more each sort of has
their own bubble which was represented
on the map
and they don't actually have any idea
that a greater number exists outside of
this
which is currently killing everyone in
said circle
just don't think too much brain you'll
hurt yourself it's it's
in in layman's terms yeah it's basically
highlander
which in case you don't know involves
immortals killing each other so that
there can only be one
beth constantly says that they shouldn't
terminate each other which would
actually lead to them living happy and
peaceful lives
a bit of empathy would have went a long
way then we wouldn't have had
such an amazing episode now rick warns
that stuff is gonna get weird which is
what happens when you make a copy of a
copy
this is often seen in photocopying and
is something that's
known as generation loss in which each
time you duplicate something
it diminishes in quality this effect was
actually used on the title screen for
loki
and over time it can lead to massive
changes and things that are completely
illegible
things do get super freaky later on when
we see a hills have eyes
slash texas chainsaw massacre home but
we'll talk about that later on in the
video now in order to disguise
themselves
they dress up in a smelling squid
costumes and yeah
that that definitely looks like a well
you know now they destroy one of the
ships
only to discover that the squids are in
fact decoys with way better costumes
some of these decoys then roll through
the country destroying other decoys
whilst the decoys also destroy each
other we discover that the chip is
planted in their brains
and get a nod to the brain scene from
the film hannibal as well as rambo first
blood where rick blends into a wall
another node to terminate his drop when
summer cuts are on with a razor blade
and this is then ripped off which is
something that the t800 did in the film
to show that he was real to miles dyson
more on that movie in our episode one
breakdown later in the video
now the family are captured by a leather
face as rick
that explains because rick is a bit lazy
that the further down the line you get
the lazier the copies do too
there's one that's been skinned alive
which says kill me and this is a call
back to aliens in which a character that
had a chest burst
inside them was strung up to a wall and
said the same thing
they're fortunately saved by a kindly
wooden rick who takes them to a
sanctuary for the decoys
known as the cause a lot of families
here are missing their ricks
potentially because he saw that the
remainders would head in this sort of
peaceful direction
and simply didn't want to be part of it
i love how the leaders are also based on
ventriloquist dummies
as the decoys are just puppets of the
real rick jerry as always messes things
up though
and we cut to a family watching the sun
set which is typically a trope used in
tv shows and movies to showcase when a
character is accepting of their death
they're exterminated by what is that is
is that the real is that the real family
is that i think is that the real one and
it might just be and he calls out all
the decoys using a giant head
that's similar to show me what you got
and we see a woven one as well as a
block one that i think might be another
minecraft
i'm not 100 sure mate as i've never
actually played it because
because let's be honest i spend all my
time making these mediocre videos anyway
the president doesn't want to get
involved because he's realized the
electoral college
might just want to keep slavery going
next the family arm up and beth gets a
plasma rifle
summer gets a double-bladed lightsaber
morty gets a whip
and jerry jerry gets a revolver it leads
to all-out war in a hilarious showdown
in which the plan of the decoys all
wiping themselves out one by one comes
true however
someone's dressed as muppets to appear
as decoys
they come to the conclusion that rick is
sorry for making duplicates
especially space beth and that he loves
the real one
summer stabs one through the chest which
might be a reference to saving private
ryan
might be a reach but rick also calls
himself a god
at the beginning of the episode rick and
morty of course said that they were
going to kill god
so it's quite fitting that this episode
ends with the death of a god
interestingly we can see that one bites
down on his tooth which blows his head
off
and if you cast your mind back to the
last episode you might remember that
rick said they all had suicide capsules
in their teeth
which he'd planted there for the family
just as it seems like a happy ending
they're killed by mr who wants to hunt
me who has now become a murderer because
no one will hunt him
we jump to a family in space returning
with space beth
who have just been alerted that a decoy
family has been killed
now i really really want to believe that
this is the real ones because
space beth is with them but in all
honesty
who knows at this point i just don't
know now go to the post-credits scene
and we see jerry varnishing himself and
though
morty was worried it might look like
blackface he does seem okay however
he's attacked by beavers and used as a
crib for their children
unable to die he remains buried in the
dead for centuries
and is adopted by the new inhabitants of
the planet they do cowboys before
christians
which might show that there's been two
entire timelines at the very least
in which jerry has been used and
repurposed it's a hilarious post-credits
scene
and probably my favorite in the show so
far but let me know if you disagree or
not
either way incredible episode and i'm
absolutely loving the season so far
it's been hilarious with these first two
and i'm very hyped for what's gonna
happen next time
okay now as for episode one i thought
i'd do some of the best easter
eggs in it now firstly we catch the pair
being chased by a creature that feeds on
crystals depicting alternate realities
not only is there a blade reality we can
also catch one that shows the original
doc and marty short that justin roiland
did for channel 101
the pair land in the sea and meet a
parody of neymar and aquaman
in mr nimbus nimbus actually means a
cloud or halo surrounding a saint
and i've heard this man gives people
heaven in the bedroom now he is
apparently rick's nemesis
and the pair and are posting him over
dinner where he smashes wine bottles and
shouts another this is something that
thor did in his first solo film
and that loki recently did in the third
episode of his show
morty also has jessica over and i love
how they turn on the tv
and see that the last channel was a
nintendo 69 one
which we learned is something that rick
watches all day so it's pretty funny
that he had this on the tv earlier in
the entry
now we discovered that rick has been
aging wine up in a narnia-esque pocket
dimension
with a family who's headed up by a
creature named hoovy due to time moving
differently in this dimension so that
rick can mature wine quickly
we watch his morty removing hoovey for
some time and creates a rivalry between
the natives that spans
centuries one of the characters is
called bova which could be a note of the
cow humanoid from marvel comics
due to them being able to speak and also
their clothes
the kingdom they create also resembles
castle black from game of thrones quite
a lot
and some of the characters in got
standing guard for the white walkers
the locals spend decades looking over
the doorway for when morty eventually
returns
after morty is attacked he arms up and
comes back
but during this we see as an outcast is
recruited by a sorcerer
and they also study a broken blade which
looks a lot like the one from lord of
the rings
after morty leaves a glove behind it's
discovered similar to the arm from
terminator
and this allows them to advance
technologically to the point that
they're able to send someone known as a
traveler through
which might be a reference to the time
travelling graphic novel by neil gibson
morty travels back to see an older
version of himself that says you're
early
which is a nod to the ancient ones
saying in avengers end game
it's revealed to be a simulation and
rick journey's there to save morty
they find troubled water and end up in
too deep
but are saved by mr nimbus and we learn
that jessica had a completely different
journey
she spent years in their dimension to
the point that they created ai
and were all wiped out by it the episode
ends with jerry and beth finally getting
their threesome
with mr nimbus yay now as for the two
episodes
really really enjoyed them and had a
blast breaking them down for you in this
video
obviously if i missed any of the easter
eggs then make sure you comment below
and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out breakdown of
loki episode 3 which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time you son of a
[ __ ] take care
peace